Are you Christian? I'm guessing.
>> What denomination?
>> I'm an original Quran only Christian.
>> Original, sorry.
>> Original Quran only Christian.
>> Mhm.
>> What does that mean? Quran only
Christian. What's that mean?
>> Uh, so it's it's a Christian that
believes in the original Quran before it
got tampered with. So these are
Christians that believe that the Quran
was actually a real book that Muhammad
was a disciple of Jesus that spread the
gospel in Arabia and that um man like
during the time where they was having
issues with recitations of the Quran
when he burned certain copies you know
that's when the original got corrupted
and now we have this issue of these
different Qurans now
>> Muhammad was a disciple of Jesus
>> how
>> well he he was in Arabia actually
preaching the gospel so he wasn't like
directly a disciple but like a discip
Disciple is the one who who follows
Christ and you know studies Christ and
and and Christianity and so uh he
different definitions of a disciple.
>> We could we could
>> so why is there differences in the
teachings of Muhammad very specific
differences when it comes to the Bible
for example the pharaoh being a king or
the pharaoh being a pharaoh right in
certain time periods.
>> Yeah.
>> Why why are those those why are there
those corrections in the Quran in the
Bible?
>> Yeah. So, so let me So, number one, in
the Bible during Joseph's Jo during the
time of Joseph, you do have Pharaoh
being called the king of Egypt multiple
times. So, he was called both from what
>> you know what I'm referring to, but like
why are there differences in the two?
>> Gotcha. So, the parts that are different
from what that you'll see in the Bible,
those are the parts that UMA corrupted
and interpolated. So, how we know how we
can see the truth like cuz there's some
truth still remaining in the the the
Quran today and how we judge that is um
by the Bible. What agrees with the
Bible, we know that that's that was the
original message of the Quran. What
doesn't agree with the Bible, we see
like, okay, yeah, that that's been
corrupted for sure. It sounds actually
what it sounds like is you've taken the
Muslim standpoint on Christians and you
flipped it and you said this is what
we're going to do to you and we're going
to try our best to prove the opposite.
>> Chad, I've only known you for maybe five
minutes now and I love you already. I
love you, dude.
>> You're sharp.
>> My Christian cousin. [laughter]
>> That's right.
>> All right, so enough trolling.
>> That's exactly what this is.
>> Look, again, I'm a layman, right? Like I
can't argue [laughter] a lot of the
stuff you're saying, but like come on,
dude. You could do better than this.
>> No, no, but that's why Hold on.
>> No, no. Say what? Say my position is
stupid. You It's It's a stupid position,
isn't it?
>> Yeah, it is. It is.
>> I agree. I I agree that everything that
I just told you and presented to you and
the way that I presented it to you and
my method of presenting it to you was
facious. It's It's I can't say a certain
word, but it's absolutely ridiculous.
>> It's ridiculous. Okay. But look, can we
can we first accept that we're dealing
with concepts that are above our pay
grade? Because you don't read Arabic.
Jay does not read Arabic.
>> Yes, he does.
>> Okay. Jay, read verse 90 for me.
>> I'm going to give you another example.
We can read it together.
>> Before you do that, I want to I want to
land my plane on this, right? Cuz Chad
understood what I was doing and he sees
that what I was doing was it was
intellectually dishonest. The method is
ridiculous. It's ahistorical, right? It
just makes no sense. And so this is
exactly what I did. I just flipped the I
just flipped roles, Chad. And I just
What you go through, that little process
that you went through, that little
confusion and that what what are you
talking about? That's exactly what
Christians go through every single day
when they converse with Muslims. When
they say, "Oh yeah, we used we believe
in the original Bible, but the one you
have has been corrupted, but there's
some truth in it." Well, how do you know
what the truth is? Oh, well, whatever
agrees with the Quran, that's the parts
that's good. What disagrees with the
Quran, that's corrupted. Oh, and by the
way, Jesus was a Muslim. Paul was an
antichrist.
>> That claim, that methodology of going
about the the Bible is simple because
what what Muslim scholars do is they
say, "Hey, we've authenticated the Quran
to be preserved 100%." Right? But we
believe in the we believe in the Tawra,
right, for those people of those times,
right?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay, great. However, we know or we
claim, right? I don't want to insult
you. We claim that the has been
corrupted and we haven't we don't even
know where the inje is. It's gone.
>> Right?
>> So, I know I know you're flipping it,
right? But it's like the methodology is
not wrong if your claim is simple. This
book has been authenticated,
>> right? And within this book, there's
things that you'll find in another book.
>> Okay? So, watch this.
>> The opposite cannot be true because we
haven't authenticated the previous one.
>> Okay? Watch what I do. Our scholars have
authenticated the Bible. We've
authenticated the Bible. We know the
Bible is true. We have it.
>> You're saying what we're saying is no
one agrees with.
>> I can say the same thing to you that
you're building off of a premise that no
one agrees with.
>> No, but look, I'm not going to argue
this because I can't I'm a layman. I
can't argue this, right? So, it would
just be intellectually dishonest. So,
I'm gonna stop here. My point in coming
into the stream was I heard you reading
verse 90 here.
>> Okay. I I do I do appreciate you being
See, this is a this is something I can
respect, guys. Like, cuz this isn't a
he's not dodging or this isn't a I'm
changing the topic or whatever. He's
acknowledging, okay, you know what? I
there's a limit to how I can argue this
and I'm going to be honest about that.
Um, so can is it okay that we can talk
about what I what I feel like I could
talk about? I appreciate that.
Absolutely.
>> Absolutely. When people try to change
the topic dishonestly, that's where I
hold their tail to the mud. But him?
>> No. No, dude. I'm not a lame. It is what
it is. Like 43, man. Like, come on. I'm
not 40 years old that studied the Medina
and Mecca for 50 years. But look, my
point is you guys are arguing a very
nuanced, highly intellectual discussion,
right? Where it's like, I mean, come on,
Jay. When I heard you reading uh verse
90, bro, I have it in front of me. Okay.
You said, let's see, you said
it's
>> Yes. Right. Now, what is what does Eban
Kir say?
>> Your your pronunciation. What does Kadir
say?
>> I know you grew up in Dearborn. I know
you didn't go to a proper Muslim school.
Chad, okay, now you're talking way above
your pay grade. Chad, listen. Listen,
Chad. Now, now you're starting to lose
the respect a little bit. Hold on, hold
on, hold on. So, what does I was talking
about god logic? I'm not
>> What does What does I say? How does he
read this verse? I don't know.
>> Okay, because you just said it's not
ina, right? That's what you just said,
right? It's from literally what I'm
reading right in front of me.
>> Okay. Now, what doesban say?
Because you said that I read it wrong.
Right.
>> This version is
>> It's not right. It's not.
>> It's not. Definitely not.
>> Okay. Now, I want you to I'm not going
to read it. I want you to read it. What?
>> No. No. Right there. Make it there. Do
you read Arabic or No.
>> Yes.
>> Read the screen.
>> Okay. So at the end of
>> read it just read it in.
>> No.
You don't know how to read Arabic. You
don't know how to read Arabic.
>> What's after the wow? What's after the
wow?
>> The wow.
>> What's after it? Alif. So you say
>> and then there's another al if
so you don't he doesn't know. He doesn't
know Arab.
You guys know that has also [laughter]
>> I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
>> Any other in the Quran?
>> Yeah, exactly. So, read read it. Read
read how says it. Read how IBM Kar says
it.
>> You want me to listen to it?
>> Yeah. No. No. Read it how IBM. Yeah, you
can listen to it, too. Yeah. Yeah,
that's a good idea. Why don't Why don't
you play it? So, God logic, I'm saying
that that says
>> and he's saying he's saying that it
doesn't say that. So, can you just play
that for us just so we just so we're
clear? It does say I keep forgetting the
first al if it says dude.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> I wish I could put my mouse over it.
>> I'm gonna play it. I'm play it.
>> So before before you play it, I just
want to I want to give my pronunciation
then he gives his pronunciation. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Now you say it your way.
>> Okay. Okay. Go ahead. God logic. Which
one is it? All right. [snorts]
Did y'all hear it?
>> Did Did he say the way I said it or the
way he said it?
>> Now go to the reciter. Perfect. Now go
to the reciter. Pickman.
>> He's got That's the only option there.
>> Okay. Go to quran.com and pick. This is
a different see. See, before you try to
correct Arabic, I recommend you learn
the Quran.
You don't know how to read.
You you don't know. Hey, you don't know
that has al at the end if you don't know
that. You don't know. You don't know if
has at the end of it. Go to any
at the end of it. Huh? Any in the Quran
has
go to
you speak. Okay. Look, you you maybe
maybe you you know a little Okay, that's
fine. You don't know the Quran. You
don't know the Quran.
I'm a [laughter] layman. I'm 23 years
old. I'm not claiming to be a scholar.
I'm asking you to stay lay. And by the
way, uh for the recitation, listen to
it. I came I came upon I came upon Arabs
that don't know that you have when it's
in plural. Look, look at the top of the
of the al if it has a little it has a
little circle. That's
you don't you don't say ah unless it's a
hamza and you go logic. Do me a favor.
>> You don't You don't know that the
>> a different recitation.
>> Yes. But you were saying that I was
reading it wrong,
>> which it wasn't. It was a different
recent recitation.
>> You thought it was wrong, which is the
point, a different Quran. And you
thought it was wrong because you didn't.
>> We've got to recognize it as your own
Quran. That's the difference. We've got
to a point
>> that we realize you don't know how to
read Arabic.
>> Yeah. And you don't know that there's a
different which has a different meaning.
>> Yes. So, we reached the point that you
don't know how to read Arabic, which is
fine, but don't pretend.
>> Yeah. Be humble, [laughter] man. Be
humble.
>> Can you pull up the different
>> We're sorry that We're sorry that your
prophet was illiterate, man. We're sorry
that your prophet was illiterate. You
don't have to follow his sunnah and be
illiterate, man.
>> What's the ad?
>> One second, guys.
>> Why are you saying that in a negative
connotation?
>> Yeah. Hold on. Let's Let's bring this
all to So, we all understand here. So
Chad,
>> they're so they're not they're not
saying,
>> "Look, Chad, Chad, listen. They're not
saying that how you recited it the first
time is incorrect based off what you
were reading because that's a particular
reading." Okay?
>> So what we're doing is is we're showing
you a different reading, not the same
one that you're looking at. You recited
it correctly. This different reading is
ina. Okay.
>> Exactly. That's what he chang and your
claim I understand and your claim is
saying that the different recitation is
leading to different meanings.
>> Yes.
>> As you're saying in means you are and
you're saying as it's in an affirmative
versus in a question.
>> Yes.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> I I understand that. I understand that
claim. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> I'm not I'm not here to debate your
claim again above my pay grade. I'm here
to say you guys are arguing something
that's above your pay grade. Like I
don't bro
these things 50 70 year old guys are
debating in Mecca and Medina and it's
like who are we? Why why is this such a
point of contention for you when it's
like there's so many other things that
you can debate when like come on Jake
I don't want to insult you bro I know
you're I know you're you're not an
educated guy from Medina. Yeah, but hold
on, Chad. Let's let's address that
because I kind of actually like your
question or what you're saying is, you
know, there's other things that we could
be debating or talking about oneness of
Allah or the prophethood of Muhammad or
whatever. Why are we so focused today?
Why are we focused and hyper tunnel
visioned on the textual variance of the
Quran? And this is why, bro. This is
why. Okay.
>> No, no, no. The reason why
>> that's not what I'm saying. But that's
not what I'm saying. I'm saying why.
>> But let me No, you you just said that
though. Let let me tell you why.
>> No, you misunderstood. Let Let me
rephrase. Look,
>> you guys are Christians. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> You have a lot to talk about within
Christianity, right? I I have Christians
friends. I know what they talk about
when they go to church, right? It's You
guys do a lot. They never talk about
disproving Islam at church. You're
basically doing online church.
>> It depends on what church you go to,
man. There are some churches.
>> Fair enough. Right. But it's like from
my experience, my my Christian friends
aren't telling me, "Yeah, we're sitting
in church listening to how to disprove
Islam." They're talking about Christian
stuff. So it's like why are you
>> Yeah. So I'll tell you why. Let me So
remember again, you're asking why. So
the reason why is because number one,
Islam has a is a pyic against
Christianity. It is. When I go and I do
this myself, I I go out and I do
evangelism or Christian da'wah in
different places, okay? Different
popular places that's populated. And in
these places, there will be Muslim
stands or tents, right? Giving da in and
Islamic material with their tents and a
sign saying Jesus is a Muslim or we love
the prophets. Moses was a Muslim.
Abraham was a Muslim. Jesus was a
Muslim. You become Muslim. you don't
lose Jesus. This is their message to
Christians. So the reason why I for
example am addressing this is because
Islam is a pyic to Christians who are
unaware and uneducated on Islamic
matters. So we are here people like me
Jai daughter of Christ life and others.
We're here to equip not just Christians
but also Muslims with the truth. Because
when lies are being spread, no matter
what religion you're in, if lies are
being spread, mass produced, dude, for
years, mass- prodduced, it is incumbent
on us as human beings and as Christians,
servants of our Lord to tell the truth.
Even even to you as a Muslim who you're
not a Christian, we especially need to
reach you then because you know from our
paradigm, you're not saved. You know, so
we got to give you the truth. And this
is a huge it's a huge like anchor to a
lot of the Muslim faith that the Quran
is unchanged, untampered with, never
corrupted, while the Bible's been
changed, corrupted, and tampered with.
>> I see what you're saying. Basically,
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to evangelize Muslims by trying
to say that, hey, this cornerstone of
your belief, that is the preservation of
the Quran, we're going to try our best
to disprove this so we can try to
evangelize you towards Christianity. But
again, I think you're thinking of this
too much in like the YouTube social
media space that Muslims have a
cornerstone of their belief that they
that they surround their entire belief
based on the preservation of the text.
It's like, yeah, that is in there, of
course, right? But I mean, to be honest,
bro, Muslim and Muslims, if you talk
about preservation of the Quran, they're
like, "Yeah, and like that's not they're
not thinking about
>> Yeah. They have this within the
>> If you listen to talk about the topic,
listen to how he talks about it. He
tells you that the beginner level, the
beginner level, they they have no idea.
They doubt it. They disbelieve you. Then
they get a little deeper into it. Then
they just start regurgitating what their
scholars say. Then you just get deeper
deeper to that advanced level. And then
you start seeing the problems between
the standard way that Islam presents the
preservation topic and what Islam
actually says. So the scholars that you
guys look up to who told you since you
guys were little kids as Muslims or if
you're converting to Islam, they told
you when you converted to Islam that
there's only one Quran doesn't change at
all from Muhammad till today anywhere in
the world. It's the same
>> that that's what they say. It's a lie.
>> That's your claim. But I see it. Look,
>> we don't need to claim. We got evidence.
>> Let me play it again. Let me play it
again.
>> Literally that's literally what Yaserati
said, bro.
>> Yeah.
>> Not just him, but other the other
scholars. Play both of them, Jai. Let
let's play let's play this guy. Uh let's
play hyam siki because he's he's got
something good to say about this and
then we'll then we'll play afterwards.
>> Never fails. You repeat a Muslim and
then the Muslim just says you said it.
>> All right. So check this out. Check this
out. children.
>> Many pe mo most I don't know many
Muslims grow up not knowing anything
outside of the house tradition and they
don't get exposed to the idea that there
are other reading traditions and that
there are Quranic variants and that all
sort of this whole system framework that
I discussed and it might be surprising
to some people but um and unfortunately
actually so I have heard some preachers
that that do say that there's only you
know one reading or one Quran or or
something like that and um you know if I
were to be very generous I I would say
that that falls under the umbrella of
like lies to children if that makes
sense. So lies to children. Lies to
children.
>> All right, that's one.
>> Who's
a he's a Quranic Islamic scholar?
>> I don't know. [snorts]
>> You know yakari, right?
>> Yeah. From Yak institute.
>> Uh not sure if he associated with Yak. I
don't know but he might be. So listen to
listen to what he says. Every single
student of knowledge knows who studies
that the most difficult topics are and
the concept of and the reality of and
the relationship of theatic with the and
the preservation of the is it one is it
three is it seven and the relationship
of the to the this is a topic that when
you're the beginning beginning student
of knowledge you're like what is all of
this going on here when you go a little
bit more you learn to simply memorize
what your teachers say and regurgitate
it out and you don't fully comprehend.
When you do a deep dive is when things
get very very awkward and difficult. And
this isn't new. This is from the time of
the Sahabah in the or the
hadith of the that when the prophet
mentioned the issue of and that there
are different and whatnot. This is in
the version of Muslim Ahmed says
authenticith
in my heart a doubt came that I hadn't
had about Islam since the days of
this is not a joke brothers and sisters
the issue of
caused confusion to somebody whom the
prophet said if you want to listen to
the Quran directly listen to is not some
even average sahabi he is the of the
Quran he is the master. He is who he is.
And he goes,
"What is all of this stuff?"
>> Look, we go to the scholars, these
people. He went to Medina. You mentioned
Medina earlier. He went to Medina. He's
been there. He's got the degrees. He's
coming back telling us the secrets.
He didn't say anything that was
secretive.
The pronunciations is really some of the
hardest part of memorizing the Quran.
Like it when I first started memorizing
Quran, it took me like for one full
page. Yeah, I'm not going to lie, man.
It took me like 3 weeks.
>> No, when he says first started
>> when he says, he doesn't mean the
pronunciation. He means the of the
different seven different
>> the variant versions of the talking.
>> Look, regardless, you guys pull someone
else up here. M's been talking a lot. I
appreciate meeting you both. Um Jay, it
was nice to meet you, man. God lo it was
nice to meet you. Thank you.
>> You too, man. You're welcome anytime,
bro. You want to talk about Christianity
or anything like that, you're
>> next time with something that I'm more
educated on. uh um next time. But may
God guide us all.
>> Chad, let me ask you a question really
quick. Did you Did you Did you just come
up here to tell us that we shouldn't be
talking about this topic?
>> Not 100%. That's 50% of it. The other
50% is Well, yeah, bro. 100%. But like
the other 50% is you guys are
Christians. There's a lot to talk about
within Christianity. I feel like what
you're trying to do is just like
evangelize Muslims by attacking one
specific thing when it's like, okay, if
you want to do that, that's that's your
prerogative. I can't really say much.
>> We attack multiple things, man. You if
you if you check out my channel, bro,
it's a multitude of topics that we that
we attack. It's not just this, but this
is a huge one, though.
>> Okay. Look, when I look at the way
Muslims evangelize, it's very different.
It's very different than the way
Christian than you guys are
evangelizing.
>> Yeah. We don't lie. We don't lie.
>> Google again.
>> I'm ad hom.
It's been said before me. I didn't make
that up. Dawa is deception. That's it's
a fact. Show me one honest honest guy
who is [clears throat] dawa.
>> Okay, look. Dawa is very simple. When I
when I see all they talk about is
they talk about the prophets. They talk
about the history. They talk about how
it's going to make your life better.
Like they don't talk about sexity
[clears throat] though and they lie
about Islam too. They're the ones who
are saying that the Quran there's only
one Quran. They're the ones who are when
when he said that that these preachers
are going around saying there's only one
Quran. He's talking about all of these
dies. That's who he's talking about. So
the people who are going around saying
there's only one Quran. There's only one
version. It's been the same.
>> I feel like Jay, you have something in
your past that hurt you which I don't
want to get into.
>> Yeah. He has he had in his past you know
way before he was born who wrote that it
was different
>> but regardless but regardless
>> genuinely you're a smart guy
>> as well was 1400 ago years ago in his
past
>> do you really do you really think this
is a good way to like argue come on Chad
I don't want to argue I want to go and I
I tried leaving but you asked me this
question [laughter]
>> all right have a good day all right have
a good Hey Chad,
>> we appreciate you for coming, Chad.
>> Like like I said, Chad, I'm I'm live
Mondays, Wednesdays, and Fridays. So if
you ever free and feel like chopping it
up, just come through. All right.